desi banks has over 12 million social
media followers but he recently shout
out my podcast that that phone screen is
different from that comedy stage there's
only one take on that stage
what's the worst bomb oh man i had
people walked out bro i was like yo and
i it's like i felt it but i was like i'm
not going to stop i'm going to keep
going just muscle through i'm going to
wrangle them in yeah
i had some good shows that i had some
okay you know i know you know you
learned to deal with it yeah it's the
best teacher yeah man
you know once you don't felt it at one
time it's like okay i'm good man and if
it come again i know how to deal with it
it'll come again yeah i'm not putting
voodoo on you no no no no
i understand yeah man so it's like yeah
and that wasn't the only time that
wasn't the one it's been plenty of times
i don't want a room it's like quiet and
i haven't got what you know i
said joe you know hit him with a point
like i'm a comedian that's interviewed
over 400 comics and everyone bombs but
that doesn't change the fact that